[Music]
there are a few places on earth less
hospitable to life than the bone-dry
Sahara Desert yet it wasn't always this
way 100 million years ago during a
period known as the mid-cretaceous a
gargantuan river system flowed across
the region from modern-day
Egypt to Morocco the whole world at that
time would look rather different to us
the continents had yet to assume their
current positions extreme temperatures
were common and fierce storms made life
unpredictable dinosaurs flourished on
land
pterosaurs roamed the skies and giant
marine reptiles and sharks swam in warm
seas small mammals our ancestors lived
quite literally in the shadow of these
extraordinary creatures in this world of
huge predators the river of giants which
is what some call this region of what is
now northern Africa stood out as
particularly dangerous in most
ecosystems it's lonely at the top of the
food chain there usually isn't enough
prey to sustain many predators yet an
incredible variety of aquatic prey
species in the river based ecosystem may
have allowed a large and diverse
population of apex predators to coexist
we know this thanks to a wealth of
fossils we've found in an area called
the chemcam beds many of the Predators
we've discovered had head and body
shapes that made them uniquely adapted
to hunt the different types and sizes of
aquatic prey this allowed many chem chem
predators to take full advantage of the
one abundant food source in this
environment fish this also allowed them
to avoid direct competition with the
Predators going after land-loving
animals
prey species in the river system had to
contend with attacks from all sides
including from above flying reptiles
dominated the skies a lanka sahara kheh
had a wingspan of up to 9 metres and
long slender jaws that helped it snatch
fish and small terrestrial animals at
least 7 different types of crocodile
like predators patrolled the waterways
including the roughly 10 metre long el
asuka's and multiple species of t-rex
sized carnivorous dinosaurs called
theropods lived side by side in the
river of giants spinosaurus was king
this 15 meter long dinosaur was even
longer than t-rex with short muscular
hind legs a flexible tail and broad feet
it's 2 meter high sail warned other
creatures of its fearsome size and may
have also been used to attract mates
spinosaurus long slender jaws were
spiked with conical teeth perfect for
swiftly clamping down on slippery
aquatic prey this apex predator as well
as its ecosystem is unparalleled in the
history of life on earth all that's left
of these fearsome predators are fossils
about 93 million years ago sea levels
rose submerging the chemcam region in a
shallow sea tens of millions of years
later an asteroid impact volcanic
eruptions and associated changes in
climate wiped out the dinosaurs
pterosaurs and many other groups of
animals and plants including their
unique ecosystems that mass extinction
paved the way for the rise of new kinds
of birds larger mammals and eventually
us
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you